foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unboxed I am back
and today we're taking a look at the
Radeon RX 7700 XT
amd's new I'm not really sure what to
call it I suppose mid-range GPU
whatever amd's calling it The 7700 XT
which really means nothing anymore it
could be slower than a 6700 XT based on
that but what I can tell you is it costs
450 us so it is 10 less than the 7800 XT
and based on the paper spec that means
it should be pretty well pointless so
that's rather disappointing but don't
click away because I've got a very cool
podcast that you should check out from
our good friend Kyle thanks Steve and
hey Hardware unbox fans have you been
yearning for a brand new show to watch
no well ignore your feelings anyway and
check out my new podcast super special
it's a fun show that I co-host with my
weird friend Ian and unlike Hardware
unboxed our discussions are mostly
pointless let's say I have a
particularly long celery stick I'm gonna
crash into that house I hate them I hate
them all is that a compliment or an
insult take it how you want it but how
are you working in a drive-through at
McDonald's
have you ever had a chopper called in on
that Spotlight no only in warzone
oh that burp could kill a baby
the link in the description to check out
the latest episode now by the way that
wasn't technically a sponsor spotters no
money exchanged hands Kyle has always
been really good to the harbor unbox
channel so we're just trying to return
the favor there anyway now that you've
subscribed to these super special
podcast let's get back to dissecting the
7700 XT when compared to the 7800 XT the
7700 XT packs 10 fuel cores and a
massive 25 reduction in Infinity cash
which has reduced the bandwidth by 26
percent there's also 25 less vram at 12
gigabytes and with a cut down 192-bit
wide memory bus and slower 18 gigabits
per second memory memory bandwidth has
been reduced by 31 to 432 gigabytes per
second
so it seems as though the 7700 XT is
going to be more than 10 slower than the
7800 XT making it a pretty hard sell for
450 U.S not only that but it seems
Nvidia has dropped the 16 gigabyte RTX
4062 to 450 us so it'll be very
interesting to see how those two compare
for testing we're using our ryzen 7
7800x 3D test system with 32 gigabytes
of ddr5 6000 memory using the latest
display drivers all data has been
validated and updated for this video and
in total I've tested 16 games but we'll
only look at the individual results for
around a dozen of them with and without
Ray tracing enabled before checking out
the average performance then of course
we'll have a cost per Frame data but
please note all graphs will be made
available to float plane and patreon
members okay let's take a look at what
we have
first up we have a plague Tower Requiem
and at 1080p the 7700 XT rendered 102
FPS making it 11 slower than the 7800 XT
but also 11 faster than the 4062i so
that is a decent performance uplift at
the same 450 us price point
now at 1440p the 7700 XT slips behind
the 7800 XT by 14 margin and is now only
nine percent faster than the 4062 which
admittedly is still a nice uplift but
with the 40 60 TI 16 gigabyte recently
dropping to 450 us AMD might need to do
a bit better here
and then at 4K we see the 7700 XT and
4060 TI 16 gigabyte and neck and neck so
no real winner there and with a 16
performance deficit to the 7800 XT you'd
surely just spend the extra fifty
dollars
moving on to cyberpunk 2077 we find that
the 7700 XT managed 123 FPS on average
and that meant it was 13 slower than the
7800 XT though impressively 16 faster
than the 4060 TI now increasing the
resolution to 1440p we find that the
7700 XT is 13 slower than the 7800 XT
but incredibly it was also 30 faster
than the 4062i so the GeForce GPU really
does get smashed in this title
then at 4K the 7700 XT is seen to be 16
slower than the 7800 XT but a massive 27
faster than the RTX 4062i so another
easy win for the Radeon GPU over its
nearest GeForce competitor
next up we have Hogwarts Legacy and the
7700 XT seems to struggle a bit in this
title coming in 20 slower than the 7800
XT at 1080p only matching the old RTX
3070 though it was 13 faster than the
4060 TI it was also 24 slow and the 7800
XT at 1440p which is 67 FPS on average
so again RTX 3070 light performance
though once again that did make it quite
a bit faster than the 4060 2i in fact a
lot faster in this example with 18 more
frames and then we see that the 7700 XT
did drop off massively at 4K producing
just 36 FPS which is the same level of
performance seen from the RTX 4060 TI
making the 7700 XT 29 slower than the
7800 XT
now Spider-Man remastered is the first
game where we find the 7700 XT to be
slower than the 4060 TI though one
percent lows are much better still
performance at 1080p it's not amazing
relative to competing Parts trailing the
7800 XT by 17 and the 4062i by 3 it does
look a bit better relative to the 4062
at 1440p where it was a few frames
faster though it again trailed the 7800
XT by an 18 margin
then at 4K it was again 17 slower than
the 7800 XT but this time nine percent
faster than the 4060 TI with a very
playable 72 FPS on average
moving on to the Last of Us Part One we
find that at 1080p the 7700 XT is
predictably 16 slower than the 7800 XT
though interestingly it was also 16
faster than the RTX 4060 TI
now at 1440p the margin to the 7800 XT
does open up a little here as the 7700
XT was 19 slower but it also massively
increased its lead over the RTX 4062i
out to 27 percent
and we see that resolution scaling
between the 7700 XT and 4060 TI is very
strange because at 4K they're now both
neck and neck and therefore much slower
than these 7800 XT
and the last game I want to look at the
individual results for is fortnite and
here none of the rdna3 gpus do
particularly well the 7700 XT was just
13 slower than the 7800 XT at 1080p but
that also meant that it was 13 slower
than the RTX 4060ti but as we've seen
time and time again resolution scaling
can be a bit all over the place and we
see here that at 1440p the 7700 XT is
now just three percent slower than the
RTX 4060 TI
then at 4K the 7700 XT ends up being 13
faster despite still trailing the 7800
XT by a 15 margin
okay so across the 15 games tested the
7700 XT was on average 14 slower than
the 7800 XT at 1080p which is a problem
given that it's only 10 cheaper but
we'll go over the cost per Frame data
shortly it was however nine percent
faster than the RTX 4062i 16 gigabyte so
not a bad result there though we are
only looking at RX 6800 like performance
overall
now at 1440p the 7700 XT was on average
16 slower than the 7800 XT so as the
resolution increases the value does go
down relative to the slightly more
expensive part that said it also becomes
better value relative to its nearest
GeForce competitor the 16 gigabyte RTX
4060 TI offering 14 greater performance
on average then at 4K it's again 16
slower than the 7800 XT but now 18
faster than the RTX 4060 2i 16 gigabyte
I wouldn't necessarily declare the 7700
XT as a 4K gamer given it is slower than
the RX 6800 here but performance overall
is serviceable
okay so now it's time to look at Ray
tracing performance and we'll start with
Spider-Man remastered at 1080p here the
7700 XT is on par with the 4062i and
just seven percent slower than the 7800
XT so pretty great result there it does
however fall further behind the 7800 XT
at 1440p where the margin opens up to 16
but even so it's still matching or now
just edging out the 4060 TI by a four
percent margin then at 4K it's 18 slower
than the 7800 XT to deliver 4062i light
performance so not great relative to the
7800 XT but good value when compared to
what Nvidia is offering here
next up we have fortnite and at 1080p
the 7700 XT was good for 77 FPS making
it 18 faster than the RTX 4060 ti so a
solid win here
but it was even better at 1440p
expanding that margin to 21 though it
was 15 slower than the 7800 XT then at
4K none of these gpus are able to
deliver what I'd call playable
performance at least not without the aid
of upscaling even so the 7700 XT was 10
slower than the 7800 XT but 23 faster
than the 4060 TI
the last game that we're going to look
at the individual RT results for is Star
Wars Jedi Survivor and here the 7700 XT
was seven percent slower than the 7800
XT at 1080P and seven percent faster
than the RTX 4060 TI then at 1440p it
trailed the 7800 XT by a 15 margin while
only just managing to Edge out the RTX
4060 TI then finally at 4K the 7700 XT
was 22 slower than the 7800 XT with just
25 fps to match the RTX 4060 TI
now across all six games tested with Ray
tracing enabled the 7700 XT was 12
slower than the 7800 XT while it matched
the 4060 ti so not a bad outcome there
and it seems nvidia's RT Advantage has
been nullified for this particular
matchup
then at 1440p the 7700 XT was 14 slower
than the 7800 XT on average and a few
frames faster than the 4060 TI with more
consistent one percent lows I'd say the
4K data is not that important given the
resulting performance but in any case
the 7700 XT was 18 slower than the 7800
XT and seven percent faster than the RTX
4060 TI
one of the biggest weaknesses of the
7700 XT when compared to its main rival
the RTX 4060 TI is power efficiency here
we see when measuring total system usage
in Hitman 3 that the 7700 XT increased
total system usage by a massive 34 which
isn't great given that performance
overall was much the same and it's a
similar story in Spider-Man here total
system usage increased by 30 with the
7700 XT for what amounted to roughly the
same level of FPS performance therefore
AMD is well behind when it comes to
power efficiency which isn't great
though at least in this example overall
the power usage is not too crazy
so this right here highlights the issue
with the 7700 XT sure compared to the
4060 TI even the 8 gigabyte model the
7700 XT is better in terms of value if
only just but at 50 less than the 7800
XT it ends up being worse value and this
data doesn't even account for the fact
that it packs four gigabytes less vram
there's basically no world where saving
fifty dollars to get the 7700 XT makes
sense then once we factor in the current
retail pricing it just wouldn't bother
the 6700 XT which also offers a 12
gigabyte vram buffer it's just much
better value right now then there's the
rx6800 which is slightly cheaper but
also slightly faster and it offers even
more vram at 16 gigabytes
When comparing the cost per frame based
on the array tracing data we again find
the 7800 XT is the better value product
making the 7700 XT a bit pointless and
of course once you factor in the current
retail pricing of the previous
generation products it looks even worse
now before wrapping up this review
here's a quick look at the operating
behavior of the Speedster quick 319
model after an hour of in-game load it
hit a junction temperature of 70 degrees
with a peak hotspot of 85 degrees so
pretty good results there especially
given the fans were only spinning out a
thousand RPM as for the cores they
typically clocked at 2 530 megahertz
when testing in The Last of Us Part One
at 4K next we have the sapphire pulse
which reached a peak Junction
temperature of 70 degrees with a hot
spot of 80 degrees so the exact same
temperature is achieved by the XFX model
though the fans were spinning slightly
harder at 1200 RPM and could be just
heard over our case fans the cores did
also clock much lower at 2 340 megahertz
so that is an eight percent reduction
then finally on hand for testing we have
the sapphire pure and it reached a peak
Junction temperature of just 66 degrees
though the hotspot still reached 80
degrees again we're looking at a 1200
RPM fan speed though this time the cores
managed an average clock frequency of
2450 megahertz so just three percent
less than that of the XFX model
the 7700 XT really is reminiscent of the
7900 XT release and by that I mean it's
priced far too close to the next product
up in the stack the 700 XT for example
that was 10 cheaper than the 700 XTX and
yet at 4K it was on average at 17 slower
while also packing less vram of course
AMD did eventually correct this knocking
at least 100 off the 1700 XT price
making it around 20 cheaper so then this
is exactly what they needed to do with
this 7700 XT and I expect this part will
drop down to at least 400 us before too
long as that would make it 20 cheaper
than the 7800 XT and more importantly
actually worth purchasing that it also
price it to match the 8 gigabyte RTX
4060 TI a product that the 7700 XT would
demolish at the same price point and
it's a bit frustrating that AMD finally
managed to release a product at the
right price with the 7800 XT only to
screw over the 7700 XT by price using it
at least fifty dollars higher than it
should be it also really doesn't matter
how the 7700 XT Compares with competing
in video products if it makes absolutely
no sense next to Simply priced Radeon
gpus
so that's it really you just wouldn't
purchase the 7700 XT at 450 us as you'd
instead opt for the 7800 XT it's just 50
more and therefore AMD has once again
left us scratching our heads as to why
they even bothered seriously though if
the 7700 XT it's 400 US within the next
eight weeks AMD really needs to look at
changing the way they approach these
radio and product launchers
and if that does indeed end up happening
it'll be very embarrassing for the radio
and division or maybe I'm just not
understanding the incredible strategy at
play here that sees AMD release a
product at an obviously unsuitable price
resulting in mediocre to poor reviews
followed by poor sales only to cut
prices to an acceptable level weeks or
months later I thought after the 7900 XT
debacle that they decided it just wasn't
the play and we had hoped that the 7800
XT was evidence that they'd learned this
but then they go and slap a 450 us
asking price on the 7700 XT so really
what are they thinking anyway obviously
don't buy this thing at 450 us at 400 US
it would be a viable option and I'm sure
we'll see it at that price point before
too long and that is going to do it for
this one hopefully my voice wasn't too
painful for you guys to listen to I'm
sure it'll be back to normal in another
one to two days but I couldn't really
delay this one and I just I wanted to
make a video it's been about two weeks
since I filmed a video so yeah feeling a
lot better now so thank you to all of
those who left uh some nice comments on
the previous videos that I had to get
Tim to film be a bit of a slog over the
last week or so anyway patreon float
plane sign up to either one of those if
you want to support our work and get
some cool perks in return like uh
exclusive live streams Discord server
behind the scenes content q and A's all
that kind of cool stuff so yeah check
that out if you're interested if not
that is perfectly fine and also don't
forget to sign up or go subscribe to the
super special podcast because yeah
Kyle's an absolute Legend been very nice
to the channel since we were very teeny
tiny so yeah I'd like to return the
favor and try and help him out on his
new Venture there yeah that's it I'm
your host Steve see you next time